1 Pulitzer prize-winning journalist is
sounding the alarm he's painting a
dangerous scenario of what happens
without a free and honest media Glenn
Greenwald wrote an article in the
intercept titled the US media suffered
its most humiliating debacle and ages
now refuses all transparency over what
happened with us to give us more insight
as Greenwald himself joining us now from
Rio de Janeiro in Brazil Glenn it is
great to see you a recap for my audience
what you wrote about over the weekend
about why particularly this CNN issue is
so disturbing given the enormity of the
story regarding President Trump and the
Russians right so you described exactly
how the story fell apart and it's
certainly the case that anyone in
journalism whether it's people at Fox or
people at the interceptor anywhere are
gonna get stories wrong sometimes this
was not just a blockbuster story that
fell apart but what most is most
disturbing to me is two things one it's
a long line now of stories about Trump
and Russia that major media outlets have
trumpeted in a very flamboyant way only
for those stories to completely fall
apart upon minimal scrutiny always going
in the same direction of trying to prove
that Trump really did collude with the
Russians in a criminal way and that
Russia is essentially taking over the
United States so it's not just one
mistake it's a huge series of them
always toward the same outcome in the
same agenda but the second and more
disturbing thing for me Laura is the
question of how it is that not to CNN
but ultimately CBS and MSNBC which said
they confirm the story got it wrong they
all claimed that multiple sources told
them that this email sent to Don junior
was dated before the WikiLeaks
publications became public how did
multiple sources all get the same date
wrong when talking to multiple media
organizations I want to think about how
that could begin to say yeah what their
names to say they refused to say over
the weekend when they trotted out David
Fromm and Carl Bernstein who's been
dining out on Watergate for 40-plus
years they they wouldn't even entertain
questions about that what didn't even go
into that at all but if multiple sources
I think the date was the where there was
missing one digit was it the fourth to
the 14th or something like that so given
that case how could multiple people read
a number wrong or transmitted
incorrectly to me that on its face just
putting my legal cap seems very
far-fetched right exactly I mean it
seems like it was a deliberate attempt
to mislead in which case they have the
obligation to say which members of
Congress probably Democrats on the
Intelligence Committee were the ones who
gave them that false information but if
it wasn't deliberate they have the
obligation to say how it happened
instead what they did was they brought a
CNN employee Carl Bernstein and David
Fromm who spent two days defending on
CNN on to pretend that they were willing
to talk about it they didn't bring me on
when I write about Fox News and all of
its many flaws and many mistakes and
many humiliations which have taken place
a lot this year in the last year CNN
immediately invites me on and Fox
doesn't and that's the reverse that
happens when I write about CNN Fox loves
to have me on and CNN won't and I think
that really is the issue I don't want it
to be implied that this is a problem
unique to CNN and MSNBC Fox has had its
share of incredibly embarrassing
mistakes also always in the direction of
its own political agenda and the problem
is is that media outlets now are
balkanized they talk only to their
audiences and they don't have any
transparency or accountability duties
and that I think is what's ruining
journalism first of all if I get
something wrong Glenn you have an open
invitation to come on and correct me I
have no problem I'm not a perfect person
believe me if I get something wrong I'm
happy to have you come on and have a
conversation with it so I'm not sure
exactly what you're talking about there
but I'm at I'm I like want more people
on my show we have trouble sometimes
getting people who are you know
Democrats on the show or liberal so I'm
always welcoming more voices so I'm
happy to have you on for that but it's
not just CNN though we have New York
Times coming out with stories they have
to then correct
obviously CBS Washington Post sometimes
repeat the the false stories that other
networks are printing and sometimes what
they say is there's a rush to get news
out it's just because of the speed of
the Internet
is that a plausible explanation here no
I don't think so because and this is
what I said in my article is that if
people were just making mistakes
journalistically because they were
rushing or because human beings are
fallible as we all are you would expect
roughly 50% of the mistakes to go in one
direction in 50% of the mistakes to go
in the other direction and what you're
seeing in this story is the exact
opposite virtually 100% of the mistakes
that outlets like CNN in the Washington
Post and MSNBC make are designed to
undermine and subvert Donald Trump and
to bolster the Russia Trump story just
like all the fox's mistakes are in the
opposite direction they don't mean your
show which is only a couple months old
I mean the two that Donald Trump loves
to watch most which is the morning show
full of inferred disinformation and the
evening show that precedes yours that's
the problem in journalism is these these
mistakes stop looking like mistakes when
they always go in the same direction and
are always bolstering the same political
agenda and I think you're seeing that
around most media outlets and not just
the ones that were discussing I have a
question on something slightly well
completely unrelated not slightly
unrelated because you're you really push
for transparency and in various
reporting especially when they involve
criminal wrongdoing or alleged criminal
wrongdoing do you think that in cases
like without Franken and other people
accused of sexual misty's that women or
men who make accusations should be able
to remain anonymous
do you do you think that's fair no I
think that's terribly unfair there was
in fact just a couple of months ago a
document that we're circulating around
the internet that purported to identify
men in the media who had misbehaved with
sexual misconduct and it was entirely
anonymous and everyone in the media had
read it people had talked about it and
it's so offensive as a lawyer if you
care about you process but just as a
human being who cares about ethics and
basic fairness to allow people who are
accused the opportunity to defend
themselves which they can't do if
they're being smeared with anonymous tat
Thanks I think Glenn there is a lot of
accusations flying around from years ago
ten years
20 years ago 30 years ago and all I'm
saying is people should have an ability
to respond and it's really hard to prove
or disprove things that have happened
many years ago it's very difficult for
men or women and I understand there a
lot of people hurt out there but at some
point we have to have some due process
before we destroy people's careers but
Glen I really appreciated your piece and
thank you very much for joining us